[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this is the
all new samsung galaxy s22
ultra freshly announced today and i got
some hands-on time with this new
flagship and you know what's funny we
haven't had a new samsung galaxy note in
two years since the note 20 in 2020 and
so since then we've had all these
questions like oh is samsung killing the
galaxy note are they done
with that line is it over
but i have a theory
this is a galaxy note now obviously not
by name we're still calling this an s22
ultra but clearly you know samsung was
looking for a little bit more of a way
to differentiate the ultra from the rest
of the galaxy s lineup and a reason to
justify this 1200 starting price so
honestly i wouldn't really be surprised
if samsung did behind the scenes
actually make an s22 ultra and a note 22
ultra and then look at them side by side
and like
yeah there's not really enough
differentiating these here
and then just booted the s22 ultra and
kept the note 22 ultra and slotted it in
at the top of the lineup but change the
name so yes the phone i'm about to show
you is called the galaxy s22 ultra but
uh
yeah the note is back so i picked this
phone up and held it for the first time
and immediately all the memories of
previous galaxy notes come back now like
i said this slots in right above the
galaxy s22 and s22 plus i also have a
video about those two new phones
dropping at the same time as this one so
if you're interested in those definitely
check that out link below the like
button but yeah this is the top of that
lineup so the new design that was
rumored is real the materials feel
familiar you've got metal and gorilla
glass victus plus you know the flat top
and bottom the whole thing is ip68
certified and then the shape well this
is the exact specific shape of the
galaxy notes of the past just with a
satin back now and the new camera layout
the satin back i love seems like the
word ultra is associated with like a
satin or matte non-glossy back and i'm
all about that and of course low key
while i of course love the matte black i
think the white one here will show the
fewest fingerprints if you can keep it
clean but the cameras are the weird
looking part for sure there is no big
camera bump no shelf on the corner like
the s21 ultra just individual camera
rings that each protrude out the same
amount from that flat back and the
camera rings are shiny and actually
match the rails of the phone for each
color
but look i don't think it looks that
great it looked pretty basic to me in
the renders and it still does but
honestly most other phones camera bumps
look pretty lame too maybe this one
looks a little dumber with a case on it
because you have to draw around the
camera cutouts and then it looks like
the letter p shape kinda meh i don't
know it's a good thing you don't have to
look at the back of your phone all the
time you can get a case you like or
something like that
it's just a bummer because
the s21 series all looked so much better
and the s22 and s22 plus both still have
this better looking corner camera bump
design
anyway the display up front on the ultra
appears to be everything you'd expect i
think we kind of take it for granted a
little bit at this point because they
are consistently some of the absolute
best displays on any phone seems like
that's again what we're looking at here
6.8 inches corner to corner 1440p
resolution 120 hertz max refresh rate
and this is an ltpo2 display now so the
refresh rate can modulate all the way
down to one hertz when not much is
happening for an even better mix of
efficiency and responsiveness also i was
able to turn on adaptive refresh rate
mode and 1440p resolution at the same
time so that's good you know we know
it'll kill your battery but hey you pay
for a lot of those pixels so you might
as well be able to use them all but yeah
this appears to be the world-class
display we expect again the selfie
camera cutout is still top center not
taking too many risks by putting it
underneath the display and the
ultrasonic fingerprint reader is still
in the same spot same size and you've
got that little curve on each side of
the screen the smaller s22s are
completely flat and i prefer that this
one curves over the edges a little bit
into the side rails just like the other
notes you can see the little ultra wide
band cut out on the rail under the power
and volume buttons and then of course
the biggest new feature of the s22 ultra
is a feature that came from the old
notes which is the built-in stylus the s
pen
like i said it's a note so the beloved
built-in stylus returns to the bottom
corner of the phone pops in and out
reversibly it has all the software the
screen off notes the super low latency
everything that people loved about the s
pen before it's all still here and it's
also funny this year the s pens are all
black no matter what color phone you get
but just the cap of the pen will match
the color of the rails which also
matches the color of the camera rings it
really feels like this phone just picks
up right where the old notes left off
because other than the name basically
does exactly that
also you might have noticed i haven't
even gotten to the specs yet but they're
exactly what you'd expect as a spec bump
from those older notes snapdragon 8 gen
1 chip and it's gonna have the exynos
versions in certain regions again but
it's a new four nanometer chip and then
every spec other than the baseline
version has 12 gigs of ram so it'll
start at eight but then every single
other one up to one terabyte of storage
will have 12 gigs of ram so you can spec
it up to that high sounds expensive but
you can go that high if you want to the
battery stays at the 5 000 milliamp
hours which is impressive given there is
now a cutout inside for the s pen and
there's 45 watt fast charging in the
ultra and the s22 plus but not in the
regular no charger in the box but it'll
support that fast charging if you give
it enough juice that's like 50 charge
added in 20 minutes of being plugged in
and these cameras are interesting
they're not bumped up so much in the
hardware department but there sure are a
lot of new software features so you're
still looking at quad cameras the 108
megapixel main camera the ultra wide a
3x telephoto and a 10x telephoto but
then in the software there's a bunch of
stuff there's a new nona binning mode
for high resolution nighttime
photography it'll combine the brightness
of binned photos with the detail of the
108 megapixel mode there's an improved
pro mode with new raw formats they're
doing ai stereo depth mapping for better
portrait mode photos and also just
playing around with the extremely
limited time i had with hands-on it
feels like the 100x space zoom has even
more improved stabilization that tries
to kind of lock onto subjects presumably
something contrast-based from what i can
tell there's a lot of stuff i got to
test on here especially in the camera
department to see if it's actually
better or more improved than last year
but that should all be in the full
review so for sure make sure you get
subscribed to be among the first to see
that full review when it does come out
but yeah i think we're pretty much all
on the same page i am very pumped to
test long term
the note 20 or s22
ultra and all of its new features let me
know in the comment section below what
you want to know about i mean there's a
bunch of interesting stuff the battery
of course is still huge maybe it's one
ui 4.1 maybe it's the new camera
features maybe it's the style of stuff
let me know i'll be hanging out down
there to figure it out and the full
review will be coming up soon until then
make sure you check out the s22 and s22
plus video if you're interested in those
as well
and that's basically it
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace
[Music]